all right
well good morning everyone thank you for
joining us and it's really a great
pleasure to be here today
i want to extend my sincere thanks to
shelley
and all of her colleagues
the team at walmart here today has given
us a very very warm welcome
walmart has played an important role in
supporting ontario's response to covet
19 whether it's helping to get vaccines
into arms or providing essential goods
and services
we are truly grateful for their
dedication and hard work
with key public health and health care
indicators continuing to show signs of
improvement
last week ontario began to cautiously
and gradually ease public health
measures
hospitalizations due to covet 19
continue to decline and we are currently
tracking towards the best case
projections
thanks to the sacrifices of ontarians
and unwavering efforts of our health
care workers
we understand the impact directive 2 has
had on ontarians in need of care
which is why we intend to lift directive
two in the coming days and begin a
gradual and cautious resumption of
surgeries and procedures
the ministry of health and ontario
health are finalizing the details on a
phased approach to resuming this care
for patients across the province
as we continue to gradually ease public
health measures i'm very pleased to
announce that starting today ontario is
expanding access to free rapid testing
kits to everyday ontarians
5.5 million rapid tests will be made
available each week at over 2 300
pharmacy and grocery stores across the
province
as well as through community partners in
vulnerable communities
in total the province is making 44
million rapid tests available to the
general public at no cost to them
over eight weeks to ensure ontarians
have tests available
when they need them
these tests will provide another layer
of protection support the province's
efforts to cautiously and gradually ease
public health measures
and offer people an additional tool that
they can use to confidently do the
things they love
like visiting family or dining out at
their favorite local restaurant
participating retailers will decide how
to distribute tests to best serve their
communities
including through appointment bookings
at checkout or through online orders
i encourage everyone to visit ontario
dot ca
forward slash rapid test for more
details on how you can access tests at a
location near you
in addition we are working with lead
agencies through our high priorities
community strategy to ensure vulnerable
communities disproportionately impacted
by covet 19 have easy and convenient
access to rapid tests
lead agencies will work with their local
partners such as community centers
community health centers
places of worship and food banks to
bring rapid tests directly to ontarians
expanding public access to free at-home
rapid tests is in addition to the
millions of rapid tests deployed each
week to support priority settings
including hospitals long-term care homes
schools and other places of congregate
living
we continue to procure additional tests
where possible
with a total of 157 million tests
wrapped procured directly by the
province to date
and we continue to work closely with our
federal partners to ensure we have the
supply we need now and of course in the
coming months
while rapid antigen testing will add
another layer of protection against
covid19 it's important to remember that
vaccines
remain the very best defense
if you still need your foos first second
or booster shot it's not too late there
are many appointments still available
please get vaccinated as soon as you can
so thank you very much for today i would
like to now hand it over to shelley
kiroff walmart senior vice president of
health and wellness and pharmacy to say
a few words thank you
thank you minister
elliott and everyone here today so
welcome to walmart
we are so grateful to have you here
today and first we'd like to thank you
for your leadership for everything that
you're doing to push ontario forward
during this pandemic
and if you think about it at the
beginning of the pandemic our goal at
walmart was to serve as many customers
as possible
that whether that was providing an
essential service at the beginning of
the pandemic or if it was based on our
pharmacists who have been working around
the clock to vaccinate as many ontarians
as possible
our commitment to our customers health
and wellness has never been stronger
and we have a thriving health and
wellness business where we offer a wide
range of health products and services in
fact every single one of our walmart
stores in ontario has a pharmacy that is
fully staffed with health care
professionals and they are ready to
serve and if i may i'd like to call out
a special thank you to our health care
teams at walmart we have vaccinated over
800 000 canadians alone and we are so
proud of that and in this store alone
they have vaccinated over 3 000 people
and these are the families in our
communities that we serve where every
vaccine makes a difference and we are so
proud of how our teams have showed up to
serve their communities during such a
challenging time it's actually really
remarkable
which brings us to where we are today
in the second phase of the pandemic and
we are really thrilled to step up and be
part of providing easier access to the
rapid tests
like many other retailers we're looking
forward to partnering with the
provincial government to get more tests
into more hands
and we will be doing that through our
online pickup service where customers
will be able to place orders and with
that order they'll be able to pick up a
rapid test while supplies last
so in closing we're eager to get this
program off the ground and on behalf of
walmart we'd like to say thank you for
joining us and i will now pass it back
to the minister
we'll now go to the floor for questions
and just a reminder it's one question
one follow-up and then we will go to the
phone lines following
hi my name is stephanie i'm with ctv
kitchener
my question for you is um now that case
counts are coming down will the general
population be able to access pcr cova
tests
well the pcr cova tests are currently
being used in very vulnerable locations
like long-term care homes hospitals some
retirement homes homes of congregate
living and so on
as we receive more tests we would may
re-examine that but we believe that
these rapid tests are going to be
very helpful to the general public as
well as to many businesses that need to
have people tested before they come into
work right now will these are rapid
tests now that they're being deployed is
this a sign that ontario is looking to
ease restrictions similar to what's
being done in quebec alberta and
saskatchewan
well we have said from the beginning
that we want to ease restrictions as
soon as it's safe to do so but we're
doing it in a very cautious and prudent
way
and we are seeing the case counts come
down in the hospitals thank goodness i
think for all of us
uh it's uh 2059 people in hospital today
whereas last week it was over 2 900. so
we are trending in the right direction
uh we of course
are working to ensure that this trend
continues uh but we want to remove the
restrictions as soon as we we can based
on the uh
recommendations of the chief medical
officer of health and the uh and the
scientists that understand uh these
trends very well thank you thank you
good morning deputy good morning um
we're seeing demonstrations at the uh
border crossings uh how concerned are
you about these demonstrations and how
will
your government predict it uh or how has
your government
reacted to the border crossing shutting
down the supply line
well we are concerned about the
demonstrations of course uh we really
recommend that
everyone uh get a vaccination that's our
best way out of this pandemic to
move into an endemic we're not there yet
but we want everyone who can to receive
the vaccination we understand people
have a right to protest
but as long as it's not breaking any
laws or
causing damage
it's not
spreading
language that's not appropriate so we
are watching very carefully we're seeing
we've seen what's happened in ottawa we
witnessed what was happening in toronto
last weekend and again as long as it's
peaceful protest that's fine but it
can't be destructive and it also can't
block hospitals
either for healthcare staff to access
hospitals or for people to receive
treatment
thank you david um the next one is the
senior vice president of uh hallmark if
i can ask her a question if possible
how concerned is walmart over the border
closures and the uh demonstrations how
long will it take before it affects
what's on the shelves
i think in terms of the border closures
i think you know like myself we watch it
every night and it's certainly a concern
for all canadians
and we'll leave it to the federal
government to uh to address and see if
we can move things forward i think what
i would say on behalf of walmart we're
happy to be here today to support the
minister and support the province around
moving the province forward
in this pandemic
we'll now go to the phone lines for
questions over to the first question
please
your first question comes from holly
mackenzie suiter with the canadian press
please go ahead
hi holly hi minister i wanted to follow
up about the question about other
provinces dropping restrictions like
alberta and saskatchewan specifically
are looking to drop vaccine passports
and masks uh pretty quickly so i'm just
wondering if ontario
is looking to do the same like planning
to to adjust its plans at all based on
changing indicators or
if you just have any more information
about how the reopening timeline might
change specifically around those
vaccination and mask measures
well we've already set out our opening
timelines we started on january 31st the
next phase is as of february 21st and
then march 14th
we have no plans currently to drop the
passport
vaccination
situation or masking
we believe that masking is going to be
important for some time to come and of
course we take our
advice from
dr moore the chief medical officer of
health and the people at the science
advisory table and other
medical experts and so we always said
that we were going to take a very
cautious
phased prudent approach to opening up
and that's the path that we're going to
follow
follow up
hi yeah i'm wondering as well about the
rapid test results because we know
quebec is trying to track those in a
centralized way
and i'm wondering if ontario is going to
try and do a similar thing now that
you're making the test more available to
the public
and if you're not planning to try and
track the results can you explain why
well they're not going to be entered
into the kovac system but what we're
taking a look at is more of the extent
of
circulating in the community and that
comes to us from a variety of ways one
is the number of people who are
hospitalized that doesn't tell the
entire picture of course because we
don't have all of the results of the
rapid test but it is a quite a good
indicator of what's happening in the
community we also have wastewater
surveillance that gives us some
indication of what's happening and the
number of people in icu's there's a
number of different other indicators
that we're looking at that tells us when
it's
safe
for us to ease further public health
restrictions
next question
your next question comes from brian
lilly with the toronto sun please go
ahead hi brian
good morning mister um
i i know that you said you you have laid
out your plan but your plan
going up to march 14th makes no mention
of when we might see a removal of
vaccine passports or
masks
being required so
you have looked at the information your
brief daily um while dr moore and others
advise the government it is you and the
other members of cabinet that make the
decision
given the information that you've seen
do you believe ontario will be moving
forward prior to march 14th
on
reducing the need or eliminating the
need for vaccine passports or mass
mandates
that is something that we continue to
monitor on a daily basis taking a look
at what's happening in the community as
we know it looking at the statistics on
the number of people of who are
hospitalized the number the what the
wastewater surveillance
information is telling us and so
we are willing to uh
to change if necessary based on the
evidence and based on what we see and
the recommendations that we see on here
from dr moore and his colleagues so it's
a combination of many factors that we as
a government take into consideration in
making any changes to the plan that
we've already set out
follow-up
that was a nice dodge minister but i'll
come back to it you see the information
every day you see more information than
you release to the public the
hospitalizations are trending down and
have been for weeks the test positivity
is on a downward trend the wastewater is
on a downward trend
are you telling the people of ontario
that you have no idea
of whether you plan on ever listing uh
lifting vaccine passports in mass
mandates or are we just going to live
with these forever or until you feel you
have sufficient cover from doctors
because you're the one that makes the
decision you're the one that makes the
recommendations cabinet as the health
minister so where do you stand on
well you're right we are the ones that
make the decisions and we are looking at
the evidence on a daily basis as well
the trends are going in a good direction
now but we can't
sit back on our laurels and assume
that's going to always continue omicron
is highly transmissible we have the
variant the ba2 in some parts of ontario
as well while it doesn't appear as if
it's going to be a more dangerous
variant than omicron it certainly
appears to be more transmissible so we
still need to be very careful uh we are
not telling the people of ontario that
this is going to remain in place forever
no but we're not in the clear just yet
and so we need to continue to
protect ontarians protect each other
with the with the passports and with the
masks at this point
next question
your next question comes from lorenda
rudikoff with cbc please go ahead hi
lorenda
hi there minister
with these multiple protests in
different parts of the province
including now at a major border crossing
we're not hearing from the premier where
is he and why isn't he speaking about
this
the premier is working around the clock
to work on
helping to
open up our economy to make sure that
people get their vaccinations he is
working hard with us day to day
and i know that this is a matter of
concern to him but we also need to work
with the federal government too when
we're
border crossings and so we ask the
federal government to uh to assist with
this as well
follow-up
on the rapid test the last time that
these were made available we saw huge
lineups and then in some cases we saw
people selling them later on the black
market what are you doing to ensure
that that doesn't happen this time
well first of all we know that the
organizations the pharmacies and the
stores that are offering
the rapid test some of them have their
own uh systems for
ordering some people have to order
online and then pick up in store so that
will give them the opportunity to
make sure that they don't have too many
people coming in too often to receive
the tests but we also know that we're in
a much different situation this time
than last time because of the quantities
of the tests that we're receiving
last time it was a total of two million
tasks and that were
taken from the shelves very very quickly
now we have five and a half million
tests per week that are available to
people and we know that most ontarians
want to have the test there's five tests
in each box we they know that they want
to protect their family and need them
for specific purposes and that they will
do the right thing but we also have the
ability to find people that are
obtaining tests that they don't need for
their own purposes and trying to sell
them online but with the vast quantities
available now
it wouldn't appear that there's going to
be much of a secondary market because
people can obtain them quite readily
last question
your final question comes from jeff gray
with the globe and mail please go ahead
oh hi thanks minister i want to ask
about uh directive 2
these graphs from the science table
yesterday that looked at the sort of
sustained impact
of omicron on the hospital even with a
more optimistic
uh level of vaccination still show you
know
two thousand to four thousand patients
uh well through march and several
hundred in the icu are you confident the
hospitals can
reasonably get back to business as
normal even given the fact that they
also will have this backlog to be trying
to fill
yes we know uh first of all that many
people have had
surgeries and procedures postponed some
for very long periods of time and we
want to be able to get back to be able
to perform their surgeries for them i
know this is very concerning to many
people especially if they're waiting for
a cancer or cardiac surgery but many
other people are waiting for orthopedic
surgeries and
and other surgeries as well so this is
something we want to get back to as
quickly as possible one thing that i
would note is that our government has
brought in 3 100 extra beds at a cost of
over 5 billion dollars since the
beginning of the pandemic those beds are
going to stay
because we need to
help people that have been waiting for
these procedures and yes i do feel
confident that we will have the capacity
in our hospitals to help them as soon as
possible we are looking at lifting
directive 2
very soon and i know that ontario health
and uh
others are working at lifting this chief
medical officer of health are looking at
lifting this as soon as possible so we
can get back to
all of those surgeries that many
ontarians have been waiting long periods
of time for
follow-up and this is the last question
thanks minister just and i just wanted
to ask a a sort of clarification about
your remarks off the top you mentioned
about the rapid test that uh you said
something defected this kind of thing
but in the uh
technical briefing it seems the official
guidance from
the ministry is to not use the rapid
tests on
asymptomatic people before a social
gathering can you maybe clarify your
remarks that what you meant by
being able to go out to dinner and so on
sure well there may be situations where
people want to see
a senior family member who may be very
vulnerable maybe immunocompromised may
have other concerns and so it would be
safe for the family to be tested in
those situations but not just to go out
and get a test because you want to go to
a party that's not what this is intended
for this is intended to be used to
protect
vulnerable people in our community
thanks everyone thank you